wie hoch sind denn jetzt die chancen
dass der prozess tatsächlich ausgesetzt
oder vielleicht ganz platzt ja die
chancen sind eigentlich gering
es ist ein typisches verteidiger
gespielt dass man da versucht eine
gewisse stimmung in dem prozess
reinzukriegen und natürlich auch mein
sammelt ständig und mit jedem prozesstag
revisionsgründe dass sein aber wenn sie
tatsächlich erfolg haben bedeuten dass
die abou chaker brüder alle straffrei
davonkommen würden
naja also sollte es dazu kommen dass der
vorsitzende richter muss sich
entschließt das verfahren entweder
einzustellen oder aber auszusetzen dann
heißt es noch lange nicht dass sie
straffrei ausgehen erstens würde dann
ein neuer prozess anberaumt werden und
das ganze spiel geht von prozesstag 1
wieder von vorne los und zweitens die
steuerunterlagen so wurde mir von an
gleisen mitgeteilt sind so genau und so
detailliert eine mögliche
steuerhinterziehung das also spätestens
da die sogenannte al capone falle
zuschnappen würde
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schaue ich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren